Brian why is the cosmic microwave
background so significant to our
cosmological models and in particular to
the standard model which is inflation
Theory and what are the kinds of
research that you're doing particularly
with the Simon Observatory to address
that question so the cosmic microwave
background marks the kind of maturation
of our field from an art to a science
its Discovery in 1965 provided the first
physical evidence in terms terms of
standard measurable quantities of watts
of energy of watts of power of microwave
energy of spectrum of black body
radiation that was basically an open and
shut case that the Universe was once in
a much much hotter much much denser
state it didn't prove the big bang
happen but it proved the conditions of
the universe at a time a few minutes
after something happened whether that
was the collapse of a pre-existing
universe as the initial interpretations
led to uh uh first projected it to be or
whether it was a big bang Singularity we
we still don't know the answer to that
um however we know very accurately and
precisely what's occurred since the
formation of the elements the evolution
of those elements of hydrogen Etc and
the formation of hydrogen allowed this
heat trapped from the initial hot dense
phase of the universe to cool off once
neutral atoms form then microwaves or
light waves can propagate through an
expanding Universe they uh expand cool
they red shift increases that means
their wavelength increases their number
density decreases the combination
results in a much more diffus much lower
energy uh collection of photons that we
nowadays observe as microwaves the
famous 2.7 Kelvin microwave background
discovered in Hell New Jersey in 1964
and 65 that ushered in a quest again the
progression of science at least in
cosmology is a new observation sometimes
serendipitous in this case it was uh
lead leads us to poke holes at the
pre-existing observations and knowledge
of a pre-existing model uh refining it
making it better soon though the kind of
flaws in the Big Bang model started to
emerge why did the universe have these
peculiar properties why was it so flat
so homog homogeneous so free of magnetic
monopoles that cried out demanding an
explanation that didn't exist until Alan
go proposed the inflationary universe
and that too has its like pun and its
gaps and its flaws that we attempt to
plug holes in or to bolster and to to
maybe come up with Alternatives the most
conclusive Smoking Gun if you think of
inflation as the spark as I call it that
ignited the Big Bang if you think about
the Big Bang as an explosion which isn't
really correct but it's a it's it's a
useful kind of uh analog if you think
about who pulled the trigger you know
the the implications of what we do are
so astounding it's not only scientific
it's not only to do with microwaves and
resistors and and telescopes it has to
do with philosophy with theology perhaps
and metaphysics so the stakes could not
be higher and it all started from this
Cosmic microwave background what caused
the cosmic microwave background what
caused the elements to form what caused
the bang to be in the Big Bang that's
inflation so it cried out for an
explanation on its own The Smoking Gun
the smoke from the gun if you like of
inflation are called primordial
gravitational waves this is sought to be
perhaps an even bigger Discovery than
the Big Bang itself because it's really
instantiating how did the Big Bang come
about so we set out an equest in the
early part of this Millennium to measure
the gravitational wave background using
a small telescope located at the South
Pole called bicep it's a refracting
telescope of a Galilean design which I
think is quite quite tickles me um and
this telescope did discover the
gravitation wave background this
primordial background of B mode
polarization uh it was astounding and as
predicted the world erupted in
celebration front page of every
newspaper uh and that showed you and it
was a shoe in everyone's going to win
Nobel prizes for all for Alan Guth maybe
for team members on the bicep experiment
maybe even for me I don't know um but it
was not to be so the signal that we
detected was not a blunder it was not
you know we didn't leave the lens cap on
the telescope we didn't have our Thumb
in the frame instead we measured not the
B mode imprint of gravitational waves
themselves sparked by inflation
inflation perhaps the consequence of a
Multiverse or a God uh but instead we
measured the imperator of cosmic Schmutz
of space Schmutz of dust of
micrometeorites if you like permeating
and suffusing our galaxy but not our
Cosmos so that was the kind of let down
but the reaction to it around the world
did be speak of the fact that humanity
is intensely interested in understanding
our Cosmic Origins including the origin
of inflation because that would be
potentially the origin of the Big Bang
the moment that that was happening the
press conference that was at Harvard
Center for asttr physics um uh up in
Cambridge that press conference I got a
phone call in my office very strange I
recognized the voice immediately it was
Jim Simons one of the richest human
beings on Earth called the world's
smartest billionaire
mathematician code breaker
philanthropist and and he asked me he
said Brian what's going on what's going
on indeed I I couldn't really speak to
the fact of how I felt at that moment
having come up with the original bicep
one idea and wanting to be a part of
this huge Discovery but not knowing if
it was really right of course was found
to be not a blunder not as I said not
not a mistake but we retracted the
interpretation that it came from
inflation so that left the door open
that we could do an improved version of
this bicep experiment not sensitive to a
single electromagnetic wave frequency as
we were with bicep 2 uh but we could
measure a whole broad spectrum that
could include the effect of the
inflationary waves of gravity that we're
interested in seeing but also of the
cosmic SPAC muts that we want to get rid
of so that's a systematic error those
systematic errors can only be removed by
application of another experiment in
this case we build an experiment with
lower frequencies and higher frequencies
than the CNB average them and average
them out we subtract out subract the and
that became the Simon Observatory with
my colleagues Mark develin Suzanne Stags
Adrien Lee and Jeff McMahon we have
built a team of 300 people and brought
them to the world's highest construction
site in the ocama desert of Northern
Chile we're building four telescopes uh
which will eventually become seven
telescopes joined by European and
Japanese collaborators and this will
make the deepest search ever for these
Cosmic microw background B mode
polarization gravitational wave
harbingers of the imprator of inflation
okay just quickly describe why that's
the case why the B mode
polarization are a direct consequence of
inflation uh what what is why does
inflation lead to those primordial
gravitational waves and how sure are you
of that you we know what the inflation
Theory says we know potentially what you
could measure with a
the B mode polarization but what is that
theoretical linkage that that makes you
so confident right so inflation is
predicated on the existence of a Quantum
field a scalar field like the higs may
be the higs we don't know but this
Quantum field like all Quantum Fields
has what are called fluctuations
uncertainties ripples or pertubations
those pertubations have different types
of characteristics some are called
scalar pertubations and some are called
tensor pertubations the scalar cations
provided the seed for structures of dark
matter and ordinary matter to
agglomerate in specific areas in the
early universe as we have observed with
temperature measurements from plank
South Pole telescope the 100,000 these
yeah Kobe experiment exactly these are
large scale fluctuations that are
incredibly incredibly small if you think
about the the average fluctuation as you
said one part in 100,000 that's smoother
than the surface of a bowling ball
that's smoother than the surface of the
Earth but it's all you need that's all
you need and our my colleagues are so
impeccably excellent at building
sensitive technology that our detector
quality made by my colleagues they are
able to make detectors that are
improving faster than Moore's law in
terms of sensitivity increase with time
it's doubling on a faster time scale and
we're making more and more of them and
of course these aren't just you know put
them in your iPhone we can't make them
exactly like that but we're making them
to operate at almost zero pressure and
almost absolute zero temperature to make
these detections so what are they
looking for they're polarizers so
they're looking for an imprint of
polarization that polarization the type
of polarization that has a twisting
curling pattern is called B mode
polarization that can only be produced
by waves of gravity and those waves of
gravity can only be observed to make a
cosmological imprint if they occur on
regions larger than the Horizon size at
which time the CNB form so they have to
appear at regions that are so widely
separated just like the Horizon problem
of they couldn't Comm there's there's
not enough time for them to have
communicated together so if if they are
the same it be speaks of their Mutual
origin as opposed to
a randomly or some sort of
a homogenation bit that they occur
together right late time Evolution which
would be the case if the Alternatives
were true so they would have much much
lower levels of gravitational a
background what's the time frame so
we're getting first light first you know
the very first photons or first
microwave as we call it in 2023 and then
the full Observatory begins operation on
Jim Simon's birthday in April of 2024
he'll be 86 years old he'll come back
down he broke ground with me and and my
colleagues back in 2019 he's promised to
come back down and see this just
incredible it's the largest most
ambitious experiment of its kind ever
performed